joining us now is former chief constable
of greater manchester and that is safita
farhi um hello to sir peter thanks for
joining us on the program this morning
um
tough time for the communities of
liverpool how do you start to keep a
city together when something like this
happens
well in the aftermath of an incredible
uh awful tragedy like this people do
come together um and you know serena
kennedy the chief constable has made it
clear
that she needs the support of the whole
community but it's not just about
arresting this particular individual who
committed this crime it is about the
criminal network behind them and it's
whoever paid for this it's whoever
organized it whoever transported the
gunman to the scene um you know is about
a whole criminal uh outfit there so it's
not just about this individual
horrendous crime it is about the fact
that often communities in some of our
cities have to live with this sort of
organized criminality around them and
subverting the normal system uh
operating things like the drugs trade
the market in stolen goods illegal money
lending whatever it might be um you know
and it needs all the agencies and local
people working together long term uh to
undermine this
speaking about the chief constable she
has asked criminals in the area to
examine their consciences and cooperate
with the police from your experience do
they
it's very rare really you know this at
the end of the day will be down to
either a lucky piece of information uh
from the public uh really good analysis
of of things like mobile data mobile
phone data
forensics uh sometimes another criminal
gang will see it to their advantage
in a way
to pass the you know forward information
which might lead to the uh to the
disruption of another criminal gang
so you know this mate may be
cleared very quickly it may take many
many months a very detailed
investigation but as i say it is about
the long-term aim the long-term effort
to undermine these criminal gangs
as i say which cause misery to lots of
communities we often if we those of us
who live in nicer areas don't feel it
but the fact is uh the market in stolen
goods when cars are stolen uh when
things like watches are stolen in some
of the awful muggings we're saying
seeing in places in london there are
criminal gangs behind this and what we
saw with this awful murder um is the
fact just the sheer villain you know
that the callousness and the viciousness
of some of these gangs who are prepared
to use horrendous level of violence
that's how they maintain their power and
their intimidation
sometimes innocent members of the public
get caught up in that but often when
criminal
members suffer the most horrendous
injuries they refuse to cooperate the
police or tell the police what's
happened because either they want to
exert their own revenge or just out of
fear
yeah what about this character who's in
hospital at the moment his mates came
picked him up left basically walked over
a dying child in order to pick him up
and take him to hospital the police will
want to talk to him as a mattress
emergency
absolutely and we'll want to talk to the
people around him and absolutely
investigate the whole background
exhaustively about this they may well
the police may well have a very good
idea about you know who's behind this um
what is the particular feud what's the
particular dispute that this has been
played out within
but the fact is you know they have to
get it to the criminal standard uh you
know to achieve a conviction and for any
arrests to be you know to ultimately
lead to a person being behind bars um
you know so absolutely they're going to
be investigating every different aspect
of that they're going to be relying on
cctv in the area but ultimately as i say
it's about long-term intelligence
gathering uh working with people like
the national crime agency and the
regional organized crime unit and other
forces uh but crucially other agencies
in the city of liverpool to share
information to share powers as i say not
only to arrest this individual but to
you know take apart the whole criminal
network behind them
olivia's mom will never
ever get over what happened in the
hallway of her home olivia's siblings
will never get over it but how do the
the police officers in liverpool the
police service in liverpool start to
make other
um
neighbors feel safe in their own homes
well it's through you know really good
local neighborhood policing it's been
there visible in the local community
it's about the local people having
confidence and the ability of their
police force to take this apart and
sadly merseyside police great the
manchester police says middleton's
police um are used to this ongoing
criminal activity and working with the
local people and trying to reassure them
uh but ultimately you know people will
only have confidence if they see these
criminal outfits being taken apart and
their power undermined and local people
have a role to play in this but it often
can be very very difficult and people
are going through really difficult times
and then approached by people like
illegal money lenders who say that
they're going to help them
but actually just horrendously exploit
them uh young people are drawn into the
criminal outfits into things like the
county lines networks and exploited and
young people who possibly could do well
at school um are attracted you know
thinking that they could be the next mr
big they could be you know the next
person driving around in a big bmw and
so these criminal outfits they create an
alternative value system and sometimes
almost uh trying to achieve an
alternative criminal justice system you
know and that's how deep-seated some of
this is um and why you know i know all
the agencies are working together and
sadly you know lots of police forces are
extremely experienced in dealing with
this and you know they'll be making
every effort now today to not only get
these people arrested but at the same
time try to reassure local people and
making sure local people have confidence
you know in the system in the criminal
justice system you know in in in the
core agencies and don't feel that they
have to rely on criminal outfits um you
know to help them get through life
okay so peter thank you